bien pues en este vídeo hablaremos sobre
la valoración de un ácido fuerte
de modo que observaremos que ocurre con
el ph y si la solución se vuelve más
ácida o más básica para lo cual
presentaré un ejemplo así como una
gráfica en el que podremos observar el
punto de equivalencia así que en esta
ocasión vamos a empezar con 1 molar de
ácido clorhídrico déjame escribirlo
justo aquí 1 molar de ácido clorhídrico
y bueno recuerda que el ácido
clorhídrico es un ácido fuerte eso
quiere decir que se disocia por completo
en agua y déjame ponerlo por acá abajo
si yo tengo el ácido clorhídrico en una
solución acuosa bueno recuerdas que
pasaba este se disocia por completo lo
cual nos da lo siguiente nos va a dar
primero protones de hidrógeno que como
ya sabemos estos están en una solución
acuosa y de hecho forman el litro año ya
esto le vamos a agregar any
de cloro los cuales también van a estar
en una solución acuosa de modo que si en
realidad tienes 1 molar de esto de ácido
clorhídrico tan pronto como lo pongas en
agua tendrás una molar de este y déjame
ponerlo así así que la concentración de
estos va a ser 1 molar
ahora ya con esto seguramente te puedes
preguntar cuánto vale ni p h cuál es mi
p h y bueno recordando el ph es lo mismo
que el menos logaritmo en base 10 ok de
la concentración de protones de
hidrógeno lo cual es 1 así que me va a
quedar el menos logaritmo en base 10 de
1 y eso es muy fácil 10 a qué potencia
me da 1 bueno pues la respuesta es 0 y
cuando esté menos me quedaría menos cero
bueno lo cual es exactamente lo mismo
que hacer o dicho de otra manera ya
puedo decir que el ph de esta solución
es exactamente igual que cero y bueno
otra cosa que es importante mencionar es
decirte que voy a tener un litro de
ácido clorhídrico así que lo voy a
apuntar por acá esto nos va a servir
bastante cuando hagamos un poco de
cuentas más adelante entonces esto me
está diciendo cuántos moles por litro
ya te he dicho que tenemos un litro y
que tenemos un molde y ahora con esto
déjame hacer una pequeña gráfica por
aquí la cual va a decirnos cómo se va a
comportar nuestro p h y su escala va a
empezar en cero justo por aquí por aquí
en la mitad voy a decir que tengo el 7 y
más arriba por acá voy a decir que tengo
al 14 si recuerdas justo lo que habíamos
visto es que mi primera medición del ipe
h
igual a 0 justo lo que tenemos acá
arriba con esto lo que voy a hacer es
valorar esta solución acuosa de mí ha
sido valorar sólo significa dejar caer
algo más en la jam en incrementos
controlados para ver qué pasa y lo que
estoy haciendo aquí va a ser una
valoración ha sido base
tengo un ácido aquí y voy a agregar un
reactivo en reactivo el cual reactivo
va a ser una base y esta base nos va a
dar la valoración en este caso la
solución tiene ácido clorhídrico en ella
y el ph como ya vimos es cero pero lo
que voy a hacer es agregar poco a poco
una base fuerte no sé digamos que en
este caso mi base fuerte va a ser
hidróxido de sodio la cual yo creo que
es mi base favorita así que voy a bajar
un poco esta pantalla y voy a poner aquí
que voy a trabajar con n
h hidróxido de sodio y bueno vamos a
suponer que mi solución está a 1 molar
es decir ya tengo preparada mi solución
desde antes ahora bien no voy a agregar
todo este hidróxido de sodio al mismo
tiempo lo voy a agregar en incrementos
pequeños de se me ocurre un décimo de
litro y para eso vamos a fijarnos de
nuevo en esta gráfica que tengo aquí y
bueno voy a decir que por aquí justo por
aquí voy a tener un litro eso quiere
decir que por acá entonces tendría dos
litros y a la mitad entre el cero y los
litros tengo 500 mililitros y justo en
la mitad entre un litro y 2 litros tengo
1.5 litro
entonces lo que voy a hacer en este
ejemplo es aumentar de una manera lenta
este hidróxido de sodio así que me
pregunta va a ser que va a pasar
conforme yo agregué lentamente el
hidróxido de sodio de lo que quiero que
te des cuenta es que va a incrementar el
ph bueno y la razón es que esta base
fuerte tiene baches es decir si yo pongo
aquí mi n
h en una solución acuosa sabes qué pasa
bueno pues esta es una base fuerte por
lo tanto se disocia por completo
recuerdas se va a disociar primero en
iones de sodio
ok también en una solución acuosa ya
esto le podemos agregar hidróxido
introducción negativo también en una
solución acuosa y ahora una vez que
tenemos esta solución y le agregamos
lentamente a la solución que tengo un
justo acá arriba déjame subir un poco en
la pantalla si le agregamos lentamente a
esta solución
bueno pues date cuenta que estos baches
van a reaccionar de una manera casi
instantánea cuando
hidrógenos que tenemos aquí con estos
que tenemos aquí y eso nos va a dar agua
se van a absorber los unos a los otros y
bueno todo esto recuerda es en su mayor
parte probabilístico y siempre que
estemos tratando con química siempre van
a haber algunas moléculas que no
reaccionarán por completo siempre habrá
una cierta concentración de lo que sea y
es por eso que en realidad nunca podrás
tener una concentración de iones de
hidrógeno de cero no importa cuánta base
agregues porque siempre habrán algunas
moléculas de hidrógeno que se escondan
perfectamente o que estén perfectamente
en equilibrio así que no van a
reaccionar pero como es probabilístico
también lo que sí puedo decir es que en
su mayoría lo van a hacer conforme
agregues más y más y más de estos baches
entonces estos van a ir desapareciendo
así que mi concentración de hidrógeno va
a disminuir de una manera lenta y
entonces el ph que es el logaritmo
negativo de eso
va a subir de una manera lenta también y
por lo tanto se va a ver más o menos así
vamos a empezar a subir pero de una
manera muy muy pero muy lenta algo más o
menos así esto conforme agreguemos más y
más de este hidróxido se va a ver más o
menos así ahora también es válido que
digas
este es un movimiento muy lento porque
no ocurre esto de una manera más rápida
pero tienes que pensar en algo si este
es un ph no se me ocurre a de uno por
aquí tengo un ph de uno entonces lo que
está pasando es lo siguiente la
concentración de hidrógeno han
disminuido hasta 10 elevado a la menos 1
lo cual es 0.1 molar aquí tendrías punto
molar es decir disminuyó bastante así
que aunque la gráfica logarítmica luzca
como que existe un movimiento muy
pequeño realmente ha pasado por un
factor de 10 en términos de la reducción
de la concentración de protones de
hidrógeno es decir de estos de aquí
entonces empezaste con 1 molar de
hidrógeno y para este momento has
agregado aproximadamente 900 mililitros
de la solución y con esto has conseguido
deshacerte de la mayor parte y bueno
obviamente el denominador cambia porque
estaría agregando un volumen por aquí
cierto a lo que voy es que esta es una
idea general lo importante y lo que
quiero que veas es que estas moléculas
de hidróxido van a interactuar cuando
estas moléculas de hidrógeno que tengo
por aquí las cuales adjuntar se van a
formar agua y van a desaparecer en la
solución lo que conduce
a una reducción global de los iones de
hidrógeno cosa que dará lugar a un
aumento en el pp h hasta que lleguemos a
un cierto punto donde hayamos absorbido
tantos iones de hidrógeno como sea
posible por lo que tarde o temprano
tendremos un incremento en la cantidad
de hidróxido hasta llegar al punto en el
que la concentración de hidróxido va a
ser mayor que la concentración de
hidrógeno pero aún mejor que eso va a
haber algún punto donde habrás agregado
lo suficiente de hidróxido que tendrás
una cantidad igual de la concentración
de hidrógeno que de la concentración de
hidróxido una cantidad igual de
hidróxido que de hidrógeno y ahora qué
va a pasar si tenemos una cantidad igual
de hidróxido que de hidrógeno bueno pues
es neutro cierto si nosotros pensamos de
la siguiente manera déjame bajar un poco
la pantalla y me fijo en mi cantidad
hidróxido ok y esta la hago exactamente
igual que la cantidad de hidrógeno que
yo tengo en esta solución bueno esto
implica que estos dos anulan estás de
acuerdo forman agua por lo tanto tenemos
un p hd7 así que hay un punto donde la
concentración de hidróxido es igual a la
concentración de hidrógeno y vamos a
tener un ph de 7 así que déjame ponerlo
justo aquí en mi gráfica de arriba si
nosotros nos fijamos en mi gráfica de
arriba va a llegar un punto en el cual
vamos a tener la misma cantidad de
hidrógeno que de hidróxido que vamos a
llegar a un ph de 7 justo como por aquí
y después por encima de éste
bueno pues simple y sencillamente vamos
estar agregando más y más y más
hidróxido la concentración de hidróxido
está aplastando la concentración de
hidrógeno así que vas a conseguir algo
realmente básico de hecho debido a que
se trata de una base fuerte
eventualmente vas a conseguir un ph de
14 o tal es un poco menor de 14 porque
vas
en el medio molar de h así que tu
gráfica se va a ver más o menos como
está primero como dije va a ir
aumentando algo así pero después va a
llegar y va a pasar por este punto y
esto va a pasar justo al wazin y después
vas a tener todavía concentración de
hidrógeno pero este vaya disminuyendo
bastante bastante bastante y haciéndose
cada vez más pequeña por lo tanto mi
gráfica se va a ver algo así como
ahora qué hay de interesante en todo
esto bueno lo primero es que quiero que
nos fijemos en este punto que tenemos
aquí este punto que tenemos aquí es el
punto en donde nuestra concentración de
h negativo esto es exactamente igual que
la concentración de hidrógeno estás de
acuerdo ok
déjame escribirlo así y la forma en la
que pienso esto es que la gran mayoría
de los moles de hidrógeno ya han sido
absorbidos en ese punto así que con el
fin de detener este molde hidrógeno que
teníamos y bueno me refiero
esencialmente en la mayor parte recuerda
que siempre hay cosas que no se absorben
entonces esencialmente tendríamos que
agregar un molde o h estás de acuerdo
eso porque recuerda que esta es una
solución de 1 molar y tenemos un litro
lo cual quiere decir que tenemos un
molde de hidrógeno y cuando nosotros
tenemos un molde de o h entonces
conseguimos estar en este punto de aquí
y cómo conseguimos moldeo h
pues dijimos que la concentración desde
hidróxido de sodio era 1 molar esto que
escribimos aquí y por lo tanto en vez de
poner el litro allí porque esto es un
modo por litro tendríamos que poner un
molde aniones de hidróxido para absorber
el hidrógeno un molde de iones de
hidróxido un molde de un h así que este
de aquí se le conoce como el punto de
equivalencia este va a ser nuestro punto
de equivalencia donde esencialmente
tenemos la misma cantidad y muy bajas
concentraciones veamos hidróxido de
hidrógeno en esencia es absorbido todo
el hidrógeno pero también es absorbido
todo el hidróxido que hace añadido hasta
el momento y bueno después de este punto
tuvo dos de hidróxido que agregues va a
contribuir a incrementar más aún el ph o
como que aplastará la concentración de
hidrógeno ahora qué es lo interesante de
todo esto bueno en este ejemplo te dije
que tenía ácido clorhídrico y te di su
concentración antes pero imagínate que
no
es más ni sabemos quién es este ácido
que vamos a valorar vamos a decir que es
una substancia misteriosa y que lo
primero que hicimos fue medir el ph de
la sustancia y nos dio un ph en este
punto justo aquí su ph 0 y lo vamos a
valorar con éste con el hidróxido de
sodio y entonces descubres que el añadir
un mal porque sabes que el agregar un
litro de la solución de hidróxido de
sodio has agregado un mol de iones
hidróxido en ese punto de aquí
esencialmente he eliminado todos los
iones de hidrógeno que estaban en la
solución original así que debo de haber
tenido un molde cualquier ácido que esté
aquí así que con eso podrías concluir
que la concentración inicial este de
aquí sería de 1 mola también puede saber
qué estás tratando con un ácido fuerte y
te recomiendo que veas el siguiente
vídeo ya que voy a hacer lo mismo con un
ácido débil pero como es un ácido fuerte
y una base fuerte reaccionando entre sí
cuando obtienes el mismo
de moles de ambas tierras exactamente un
ph de 7 se neutralizan completamente
entre sí y tienes una solución
completamente neutral si tuvieras una
base fuerte con un ácido débil una vez
que tengas la misma cantidad de ácido
débil la base fuerte tendría que
neutralizar la pero también tendría algo
de base débil conjugada así que en
realidad habría terminado con un ph un
poco más básico voy a hacer esto en el
próximo vídeo pero si ves que este punto
de equivalencia ocurre justo aquí en el
valor de un ph de 7 eso quiere decir que
estamos hablando de un ácido fuerte un
ácido fuerte que está siendo
neutralizado por una base fuerte y si
quieres ver lo que es un punto de
equivalencia puedes ver que es el punto
más empinado de la gráfica justo este de
aquí porque es el punto en donde vas a
pasar de tener mayor hidrógeno que
hidróxido al punto donde tenemos más
hidróxido que hidrógeno así que esto
crea un punto de inflexión en la gráfica
y solo tendrás que ver esta gráfica es
decir bueno agrega
un litro de esta solución la
concentración de esta solución era un
móvil por litro lo cual es uno molar y
tiene una polaridad de 1 por lo tanto
debí de haber agregado un molde
hidróxido para obtener este punto de
aquí así que debe de haber de otro
alzado un molde hidrógeno por lo tanto
estoy diciendo que aquí debo de haber
tenido
mol de hidrógeno justo esto de aquí una
vez que tengo un litro de mi solución
tuve un molde hidrógeno por lo tanto mi
molar y that original era de 1
en fin no quiero confundirte mucho pero
en el próximo vídeo voy a tratar de
hacer lo mismo pero lo voy a hacer con
un ácido débil